[Musik]
leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video nicht
immer zu einem neuen video bei ist von
adwords gibt es nicht mehr
heute ist die stadt duisburg weil sie
nicht das ist dieser zeit infos auf
youtube ist vorbei glaube ich meine mama
sagt auch marc du brauchst das
installationen und wiedererkennungswert
dann sagt mama macht unseren eigenen
youtube-kanal jetzt sagen und ich werde
diese gruselige and raw nimmt dann sagt
sie mal mache ich aber nur mit maske das
ist total weil dann wollen alle wissen
wir das ist ja sonst immer leute wir
haben uns hier zusammengefunden um 0.6
spät um 00 23
ich fahre in drei stunden in den
skiurlaub und ich sitze hier noch wir
haben gerade 999 1779 abonnenten und ich
wollte eigentlich eine leichte reaktion
auf die eine million machen wenn ich
pech habe erreicht dass jetzt mit der
nacht ruhig schlafen
auf jeden fall wollten wir noch ein
video drehen das ist dann vor politik
weil ich ja dann in österreich bin
eigentlich war freitag der tag wo videos
kommen sollten da ich über meinen eltern
war ging das nicht
also was willst du machen dafür dass
dann hast du dich auf dein dagegen
dürfen liegt ja aber das video das war
irgendwie nicht wenn man freundlich und
ich hab's ich muss das unternehmen was
ja keine ahnung ich war ganz komisch
leute wir machen heute den unangenehmen
fragen tag habe ich schon ganz früher
mal gemacht allerdings in abgewandelter
variante und zwar habe ich mir überlegt
jeder von uns sitzt immer hier und der
andere stellt dann die frage okay wir
können eigentlich zu bleiben und das
special
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel die frage
stelle marie was ist deine schrägste
fantasieren deinem kopf und du sagst ja
das will ich nicht beantworten
dann kannst du sagen ich skibbe und dann
stellt ihr nämlich die nächste frage
die musst du dann aber beantworten weist
das heißt man kann immer sagen nichts
kippe die nächste frage muss man dann
aber fraglich verantworten ach ja dann
würde ich sagen die schwierigen sind
ganz recht erklärt der skoda chef job
hier anfängt schnick schnack schnuck ich
glaube anfang leute ich hab gerade noch
ich auf das worauf gepostet meine story
ich habe gerade noch für instagram
unangenehme fragen angefordert ja ich
habe das vor zwei minuten gemacht damit
sie bestimmt schon 20 immerhin okay also
du musst immer ich selbst ja gut okay
was aus dem letzten monat verdient weil
das letzten monat verdient habe ja wie
viel wasser er sitzt hermann gerichte
und ich glaube das war relativ gut hat
ist damit gemeint quasi was ich an in
dem monat was auf mein konto fragen hast
ja genau das weiß man ungefähr nicht
lustig wenn du sagst du ja das ist mir
zu privat dann können wir auch
privatleute wurde euch nicht ich sitze
hier und aktualisieren manchmal jetzt
fehlen noch 218 und wir haben halt
einstiger den meisten leute ging das
schlafen
ok so rahn mit 3000 euro so viel es sind
wirklich so aber brutto muss man dazu
sagen aber 2000 guter monat bergmann hat
das gute ist halt es kommen halt immer
ende des jahres noch relativ viele
modeljobs rein und sehe immer im winter
quasi die sachen für den sommer
vorgestellt werden und kühlkosten gute
gute antwort schreiben habe ich schon
guten video titel jetzt bist du dumm ich
schreib einfach ein video viertel
unabhängigen
meiner freundin das ist meine nein ich
beantworte das direkt bei saddam okay
für ist in berlin
ach so das war jetzt die frage im
dezember habe ich schon mal beantwortet
indem wir in diesem video mit jonas
darunter gehen wir fahren dann sagt es
nochmals sehr standen es gibt euch dass
das nicht noch mal hab ich mir da schon
ab ich bevor ich habe es nur gemacht
damit ich mich extra extrem im schnee
liegen sollte und ich habe es auch
begründet hattest du schon einmal
telefonsex
nein oder was ist das wenn man so eine
hotline anruft und die dann nein wenn
wir mal in irgendeiner beziehung war ist
oder wie ich kann mir das gar nicht
vorstellen wie die macht dann ist man am
telefoniert werden keine reifen man auch
so wie du das verstehst ich habe es halt
einfach nicht gemacht dass england jetzt
hatte ich das eigentum
du weißt genau mit den fragen ja ich es
war eine ehrliche antwort er hatte ich
noch nicht nach ich gerade im enthält
von logistische und frühe aufstehen hab
ich gerade mit halt gefunden hat kann
endlich wieder so vorbereitet sein wenn
du ein uhr nachts hast du schon mal
etwas absicht bewusst ehrlich zu enden
hast du schon mal etwas absichtlich vor
mir verheimlicht so sagen wir mal drei
vier tagen absichtlich vor diesem fall
eigentlich nicht du kannst nicht durch
bin viel zu ehrlich
bei mir sind so wenn ich bei irgendwas
ein schlechtes gewissen habe oder weiß
dass alex mit irgendwas nicht okay wäre
dann sage ich das immer direkt weil ich
mir immer danach zu denken okay wenn ich
das immer hat er später erzähle dann
kinder richtig stress deswegen habe ich
so erzogen nein
ich finde immer schon so gewesen böse
das ist weil meine eltern mich so
erzogen haben damals als ich meinen
ersten freund hatte habe ich meiner mama
das uhr sagt bevor ich mit ihm zusammen
war und hab gesagt habe habe sie vor der
schule angst und hab gesagt mama es kann
sein dass ich meinen ersten freund habe
wenn wir nicht weggefahren
du bist wieder drin das ding ist von
hier kommen jetzt wahrscheinlich immer
diese standard unangenehme fragen muss
dazu sagen dass es mir eben fünf minuten
gesagt hat dann soll das video mit mir
drehen möchte und dann hat er das sind
seine story gekostet aber ich dachte die
fragen wenn es für uns beide
hast du mal in deine bisherigen
beziehungen irgendwie deine freundin
betrogen
nein noch nicht
nein spaß habe jemand ich sag mal so ich
wollte es mal ausprobieren
nein spaß jetzt muss ich wieder
aufpassen was ich sage sonst ins gericht
wie er richtig einen augen und sagt nein
heute habe ich da nicht ich will jetzt
nicht ich möchte jetzt auch kein keinen
spaß machen weil daher verstehen dass
welche wieder nicht und dann kann ich
mir wieder was sagen nicht in die
richtungen so ja gut also jetzt so
betrogen ist ja halt volles rohr will
findet also ich finde auch betrügen kann
wo körperlicher kontakt beginnt nur auf
so ein bisschen lapdance im club zählen
dazu
ich habe immer gesagt dass mit mädchen
tanzen solange ein bein dazwischen
fast wie ein bein beinlänge also soweit
dürftest du bist du hast deine füße
werden extra alex wie viel geld hast du
im letzten monat ausgegeben
im letzten monat feiert weihnachten uns
sondern gut teufel aber du bist ja auch
sonst oft shoppen
ich schätze mal so lange wartet muss
ehrlich sein schätzen also 2200 euro
aber man muss auch sagen wir hatten halt
weihnachten sagen obwohl vielleicht
nicht ganz so viel leute kommen hier
einmal einem monat verdient mit dann
wird noch der amg geleast dann werden
die 1200 für klamotten ausgegeben
dann kommt das finanzamt und möchte noch
ein paar steuern haben und schon hatte
steuerschulden leitete susanne geht's
also erst leute ich gebe sonst nicht so
viel her ist war nur spaß und 2 war ich
einen nissan micra
also es wurde das wenn er an das nochmal
bodenständig so anständig oder mache man
fragen kann das wird eine frauen kiste
aber ist auch ein süßes auto küssen sich
sogar du bist wieder drin ist immer
schon mal innerhalb von zwei oder drei
tagen hat als single war mit zwei
verschiedenen mädchen rumgemacht ja gut
also früher erhalten wird somit 16 17
oder so ich weiß noch also gut ich gehe
also ich schäme mich dafür ist auch
nicht dass mir scheißegal
einmal waren wir im party urlaub oder so
und da war das irgendwie sondern dingen
zwischen uns und da war ich auch noch
ein junger weiße da heutzutage werden
wird interessiert mich das gar nicht
mehr aber das halt daneben mit deinen
freunden
wer hat an einem abwehr kann man einmal
mit mehr und keine ahnung also das waren
schon mehr als ja das war ja das
kommando sind und waren
also 3 oder so aber halt nur so das ist
ja voll dumm bringen aber es war ja ist
ja schon ewig her
so wisse dann schreibt wenigstens keiner
in die kommentare hier beantwortet ja
die unangenehme frage gar nicht es gibt
so youtuber alter die band in frage da
denke ich scheiße hast du schon einmal
erotische fotos von dir gemacht wenn ja
hast du sie wem hast du sie geschickt
also um ganz ehrlich zu sein geht auf
meine instagram accounts und dann seht
ihr halt büro tische fotos in dem sinne
dass ist ja also ich bin ja in
unterwäsche auf den bildern also einfach
total wirr frage weil theoretisch kann
es jeder meine bilder in unterwäsche im
internet anschauen andern aber halt so
vielleicht noch gotischer nackt markt
habe ich nur gemacht
moment mal ich hab ich noch nie gelang
hat klar ja ich glaube dass jedes
mädchen sich mal im wiki oder in
unterwäsche vorm spiegel fotografiert
aber und bei mir deshalb auch wirklich
so ich denke mir mittlerweile 1000
mädels laden und bilder auf instagram in
unterwäsche hoch sei es auch in holz
oder sonst was
okay ganz daneben war so da würde ich
sagen jeder noch eine fahr jetzt okay
ach so und das thema war halt immer so
aktuell wenn man von der sechsten klasse
war hat man deshalb schon oft gesehen
dass nacktbilder von mädels umkehren
oder so nah oder das wird dann halt auch
stimmt doch einige gespräche
meine eltern haben ich dachte mir so
krass eingeschüchterte mann gesagt den
ganzes leben ist verboten habe ich
wirklich wurde über 40 nackig wirklich
und das sogar so krass gewesen dass ich
einmal mit hat die leute von köln 56 67
mit 14 getroffen habe ein bild gemacht
haben und ich konnte es einfach
niemandem zeigen weil ich mich so
schlecht gefühlt da war ich in die kita
vorbild und ich durfte bis ich 16 bin
und ich glaube das ist auch besser so
dass das keiner gesehen hat das bild mit
dem neuen hoch könnten aber nicht dürfen
nacht habe ich bis ich 15 oder 16 wenn
du noch welche beim ksc 67 treffen
möchte einmal die straße runter im
supermarkt das trübste mal die hälfte
meine leute wanderspaß aber hier wo ich
wohne hier wohl nicht richtig viele von
diesen schauspielern einer sogar ein
richtig netter der umfasst also der ich
weiß nicht ich glaube wir spielen nicht
mehr mit der wunde punkt der bund zehn
meter von mir entfernt hier eigentlich
eigentlich könnte ich da jetzt kurz
rüber rufen hast du schon mal andere
menschen beim sex zu gut also ist nicht
bauen oder die sondern live das ist
eigentlich ganz lustig und zwar waren
wir in amsterdam mit
und ich habe ja dir gesagt dass ich
nicht dabei
so habe ich habe eine freundin vorstand
aus du nicht da reingegangen aber ich
war nur ganz kurz am anfang und ich bin
rausgegangen weil auf da gab's keine
toilette und ich musste richtig dringend
essen und dann bin ich nicht mehr
reingekommen
oha so an sich hätte ich einfach nicht
gehen aber dann ist das ziemlich an
gelungen hast machst du das ganz sicher
ja aber ich wollte jetzt da nicht
ausnahmekönner fand ich machen möchte
ich dachte das ist ok in super ehrlich
über ehrlich und er nicht weil er immer
sagt ich wollte eine milliarde aber wenn
man da nur zwei minuten distanziert das
für mich nicht da kann ich einfach sagen
ich war eine verwaltung nicht so einfach
sagen das sei eine schwache blase hab
ich nur kurz dabei und die leute die
jetzt wissen wir wollen und was es geht
schaut euch einfach das video was ich
damals gemacht haben mit jonas dass das
so ein bruder oder so läuft dann würde
ich sagen war wirklich sehr interessant
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und es
war echt an sich ganz lustig so ja dann
würde ich sagen insider ist hier
eigentlich wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich
morgen wieder um 19 uhr sonst immer um
19 uhr
genau
[Musik]